- Oh, I deleted it.
(laughs) I feel like my dad!
(goofy synth music)
- I've never used Snapchat before.
- No, I haven't, I've
heard about it though.
- I'm a little suspicious.
- Young people love technology
that older people don't know how to use.
- I know that the icon is
a ghost that does, like...
- I was sure that it was
just for nude pictures.
- I could send pictures of my junk
and then it's just gonna be
gone in 30 seconds or something.
- [Interviewer] Exactly.
There's a real appeal to
that, I'll have to tell ya.
- Then it became clear that teens
were just sending funny images.
- I'm ready to snap.
(brass bell rings)
- I have to take an ugly selfie?
I don't wanna, this is
why I don't like Snapchat.
- Those are the rules, it
has to be an ugly picture?
So I'm gonna reinvent the selfie.
- This gives me an
excuse to do a duck face.
It's really bad, this is
just me bashing myself.
- Ooh, that's ugly.
- Oh, I think I hit the wrong thing.
- Dude, I am so wasted.
- You should always do a dumb face,
and the perfect caption is "date me."
Date me! (creepy laugh)
- I am so cutting edge.
- Now where are my filters?
Ooh, I can write that it's 3:20?
I'm gonna go with Hypercolorful.
My stupid fat fingers, I
feel like I'm doing great.
- Is your mom on here,
can I send it to your mom?
Oh, damn it.
- What's this stopwatch
in the bottom left?
- Is that my timer?
- Who would ever do one second?
That would be just rude, well,
I guess if it's your dick.
- It's still sad that the
picture's gone in 10 seconds.
- I'm gonna take a video.
- What'll my video be about?
(camera shutter clicks)
- Ooh.
Oh, what a minute, what'd I do?
- Whoa! Space.
Everyone's gonna see this and be like,
"When did Alison become an astronaut?"
- And now I'm gonna start
talking, and send it to my buddy?
- I'm gonna do my best impression,
Cal from the film Titanic.
I put the jewel in the coat,
and I put the coat on her!
(laughs) Oh, was that dumb?
- This is what my face would look like
if my nostrils were my eyes.
- This is like a J.J. Abrams selfie.
This combines drawing and selfies,
which are two things
I'm terrible at doing.
So this is like, if I was like,
"Hey do you guys wanna come watch me
"dance and do my own
taxes at the same time?"
- And the message I would
like to give people is,
don't waste your time
sweating the small stuff.
Life is too short.
- Oh, you can watch it
for an unlimited amount
of time for 24 hours.
- I'm about to view my best
friend Gaby Dunn's stories.
Okay, now she's at the MTV Movie Awards.
Cool, she didn't invite me to that.
I have a lot to say to Gaby.
- We had a version of this
when I was in middle school
and it was just passing notes.
- If I was in high school,
this would be a lot of fun.
- I can get into it, but I also like
to look at things, I enjoy permanence.
You know when people create
art, and then the wave
takes it away on the
sand, like on beaches?
(bleep) that.
- You know, I mean they
are not back smoking crack,
so there's worse things
to do than Snapchat.
- It's more fun than I thought.
- I thought it was stupid,
but now I'm enjoying it.
- I just hope people
don't get carried away
using it for sex pictures all the time.
In my day, we had the Polaroid for that.
But then you could just
throw it away. (laughs)
- What's the terminology,
"I got Snapchatted"?
"I'm snapping"? I'm snapping.
Snappin' 'dis chat, yo.